bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got will
here thanks so much for doing this man
thanks for having me on pomp um i'm
excited to do these every week
absolutely so for those that haven't
heard yet uh every friday will is going
to be writing
a on-chain uh analysis for uh the
newsletter
uh and then every saturday we're gonna
release an episode basically talking
about all the on-chain metrics
uh and kind of giving an overview for
the week um so maybe let's just jump
right into uh this week will
just in terms of what you saw in the
on-chain metrics that really caught your
eye
yeah absolutely so you know i think
first of all um
when we just step out and look at the
kind of uh broader macro trend
in the data that we're seeing we're just
kind of sitting in this huge
like midway consolidation zone every
every ball cycle we see this huge base
of capital that usually builds up around
two to three times the previous all-time
high
which lines up exactly where we are now
over the one trillion dollar market cap
we now have over 15 percent of supply
that's moved
which is super bullish because when we
see these
um the tops and the cycles they're
usually blow off tops
where you have these increasingly
parabolic moves until finally
you just see this huge run back off and
and decrease in demand
but what we're seeing now is the
complete opposite we're seeing a lot of
distribution
in movement in coins at these price
levels which
is showing validation from the market um
of
the one trillion dollar market cap
threshold which is super bullish
and um also we're seeing realized cap go
up
which means the way you can think of
realized cap
is instead of market cap where every
coin is is increasing in price based off
of the coins that are being traded on
the margin
realize cap is taking the the price of
every coin the last time they were moved
and then adding that up
so for example if someone bought a
hundred thousand coins
at one dollar per coin right and they
never move them
it wouldn't be um you know whatever 5.8
billion dollars worth of bitcoin that it
is that's added to the regular market
cap
it would only be a hundred thousand
dollars that's added to realize cap
because that was the last time that
those coins moved
but we're actually seeing a huge
increase in realized cap over the last
couple weeks and this week as well
which is super bullish because once
again in uh
just like i had just mentioned about the
the volume the unchained volume there's
a lot of coins that are being scooped up
in
new investors that are coming in
scooping up coins at these levels
um and that's a really great sign and
that kind of aligns with
we're also seeing a liquid supply goes
up
um going up so the way you can think of
that is
glass node basically clusters together
different addresses
into different entities and they say
okay um this
these addresses look like one person or
one entity
and then they take those clusters
and they group them into three different
cohorts so they're highly liquid
liquid or illiquid and we're seeing this
steady move of coins to liquid addresses
throughout the entire bull market this
week as well
which is just showing that coins are
moving to these
entities that statistically have a very
low
history of selling so after coins are
reaching a certain threshold of time
that they're held in a wallet
statistically the the likelihood of them
being moved goes down drastically and i
think the threshold glass node uses is
155 days for that metric
and so you you keep seeing these coins
moving to these addresses which once
again is showing that we're just in this
kind of
consolidation zone um but some of the
two of the the broader macro metrics
that i had touched on in the letter the
first one was
mvrv z score so it's just this fancy
term so
mv is the the market value aka the the
market cap
and then rv is the realized cap which we
just talked about um
and so it takes the ratio of that and
then z scores it which just means that
it it's adjusted for volatility and so
you can get these really distinct
tops top signals and what we're seeing
now is actually the metric is
going down meaning that market cap
part of it is two things so market cap
is slightly going down
but also more importantly as we
mentioned a realized cap is going
up so this metric when it when it's
going down in a mid bowl cycle like this
it's just showing that we're once as
well in this
big consolidation zone and then the
second one that i had touched on in the
newsletter was
market cap to thermo cap so thermo cap
is just the total amount of uh revenue
that's been
rewarded to miners um on the network
and so this this metric kind of gives
you these distinct
top signals where the market cap kind of
rises
um way above where the uh
the organic revenue that's being
provided to the network i mean to the
to the miners through the network and so
you see these huge spikes at the end of
the cycle
where minor revenue isn't increasing um
which is showing that there's not a lot
of on-chain volume at those levels but
price is just being bid in through
you know like fomo and all these things
that we know are um
that come at the end of cycles and the
next thing
so this is this is more so um specific
to this week
is the the stable coin supply so we've
seen a huge
increase in stable coin prints this week
um
in the last week or i'm sorry in the
last 10 days alone
we've seen over um six billion uh
coins minted between tether and u usdc
alone tether is primarily used overseas
but usdc is
primarily used by u.s investors we
actually saw a one-day increase of
22 percent from usdc which is showing
there's a lot of
demand coming from uh us institutions
which are
who prime primarily uh operates through
usdc
and it it's hard to know exactly how
much of this is going to bitcoin and and
obviously some of this is being
allocated to these alternative
cryptocurrencies
because no one can deny that capital is
being deployed into these with these
crazy gains we've seen in the last week
but at least a substantial portion of
that is going into bitcoin
and in another way you can kind of put a
uh
you know a visualization on the amount
of coin uh the amount of capital that's
going into alt coins is by looking at
the binance balance
so while coinbase's balance has been
going down
finances has actually steadily begun
been going up and i think this is a good
way to illustrate
the the whole altcoin frenzy because
binance
offers almost any altcoin that you can
think of and they also offer all kinds
of derivatives
on top of these coins so the fact that
that bitcoins are
continually being taken on to uh finance
i think shows that people are stepping
in to
try to take advantage of some of these
crazy gains that are being seen in these
coins
and then the next metric that i had
touched on in the letter is uh
asol so that's just abbreviation for
average spent output life span so you
can just think of this as the average
age of the coins that are being sold and
in the chart that you can see in the
newsletter we had this huge spike around
january right after all-time highs
around about the high 20s to early 30s i
think it was about
27 000 to 32 000 was the peak and
selling from from long-term holders but
see this huge spike in in the average
age of coins that are being sold
and since then we've seen a dramatic uh
decrease which which means that older uh
older market participants are holding
off on selling and most of the selling
is being
primarily driven by newer market
participants likely
inexperienced market participants which
is also supported by this other metric
called
spent output age bands so this just
basically shows you
the the amount of coins that are being
sold in different age cohorts
so the glass node has uh different
cohorts all the way from one hour
old to over 10 years old and we're
continuously seeing
these huge spikes in the younger cohorts
particularly the one to the one hour to
24 hour
and also the uh one week to one month
uh cohorts and we are we actually saw an
all-time high spike
in the in the one week to one month
cohort this week
um which is showing you once again that
we're just in this consolidation zone
where
um the the weak hands are selling off to
strong hands who
are continually coming in and scooping
up these cheap coins whenever the newer
mark participants are freaking out
and this is also supported by dormancy
so
dormancy is very similar to the the asol
where it's taking um
the average amount of uh the coin days
destroyed
um meaning that so like if a coin is in
a wallet for
10 days it has 10 coin days and then if
it's moved
those 10 coin days are destroyed and so
dormancy takes that and then adjusts it
for
the volume and so you get this this very
smooth
picture of selling once again from older
hands
decreasing steadily over the last few
weeks especially
and so that's very interesting because
you know you especially after the tesla
announcement you saw this huge drop-off
in that
and usually you see these long-term
holders continuously selling throughout
the bull market but we've actually seen
a decrease in that over the last month
or two so
it's possible especially after tesla
that some of these older
sellers that were just assuming this
cycle would be like all the other ones
maybe they're saying oh this this cycle
might actually uh
be a little bit different because of the
the corporate adoption that we're seeing
come online
and what about the miners like the it
seems like the miners really have
changed the way that they're thinking
about buying and selling uh or
accumulation and uh
and selling yeah that's a really good
point yeah so
in the data we're seeing miners actually
aren't just
not selling their coins but they're
actually accumulating
which is super bullish um because you
know
it makes sense that miners are more
bullish on the asset than anybody
because
they have all of their their capital
invested in
in bitcoin and if bitcoin wasn't you
know in existence then
all of their uh their capital that
they've deployed would just be
worthless right all their mining
machines would just be paperweights
essentially if bitcoin was to cease to
exist because
all of their miners are literally the
mining machines are literally created
just for the sole purpose of mining
bitcoin shot 256
so i think it's a great sign to see that
the people that are
most bullish on bitcoin continually
accumulating
i think it also has something to do with
the fact that
they're able to finance their operations
through
not just having to sell their coins but
also being able to borrow
against their bitcoin holdings but we
are seeing this
like i said this huge increase in uh
balance in minor wallets and then in
addition glassnode has this metric
called a
minor net position change so it just
takes like this trailing 30-day moving
average of the activity in minors
and we saw this huge spike in this um
during the dip down to 47
000 but we've seen a little bit of drop
off of that but they're still steadily
accumulating this indicator has been in
the green now for
over a month which is super bullish and
so when you think about
um kind of where we are in the market
cycle i think a lot of people say hey
wait this thing ran up
hundreds of percent uh in price and now
there's been this kind of
uh price um cooling right it's not still
running up in this like hyperbolic way
uh is there a belief that uh
bitcoin is just gonna consolidate and go
sideways again for two or three years
or is this simply a kind of midway point
where we actually see bitcoin
consolidate
above this kind of one trillion dollar
market cap uh and then eventually that
is
serving as that like spring or uh uh
whatever to kind of push the price much
much higher through the rest of this
year
yeah absolutely so i think we're we're
in
this uh mid mid cycle consolidation
point which
lines up with what happened in previous
cycles as well we saw these huge run-ups
all these
indicators got you know pretty
overheated and then they drew back
and uh and bitcoin just was in this
consolidation for
weeks or in in 2013 we saw this actual
90 percent decrease in between the the
double pump
that we had so you know that this can go
on longer than you'd expect but it is a
consolidation at the end of the day
um you know it's it's hard it's
impossible to to predict
exactly when it'll be over i mean we
could consolidate for a few more days we
could consolidate for a few more months
but uh one thing to just take away is
that
these strong hands these these long-term
holders that buy bitcoin and never sell
are continually buying
and the people that are selling are new
market participants
that um that are just getting shaken out
by by these moves that
people who have been in bitcoin for a
long time know they're just part of the
way that the market works
and so eventually we're going to get to
the point where the the sellers get
exhausted and and there's nobody else
that
has um coins that are that are going to
be sold
but until then we're just sitting in
this this
uh band where those coins are
continually moving to these strong hands
i think that uh as we continue to talk
every week uh the on-chain data doesn't
lie
and uh it's incredibly bullish so uh
we'll continue to keep an eye on this in
the coming weeks but
uh right now while price is going
sideways it's just massive consolidation
it's a coil like a spring
and when that thing's ready to move i
think it's going to rip people's faces
off so it'll be very very interesting to
watch
but uh will thank you so much for taking
the time to do this i think people are
really enjoying the on-chain analysis
we've linked in the description to the
new email that you've got it's a free
email
with a ton of on-chain analysis uh each
week so if people want to subscribe to
that please go and do that and then
we'll we'll do it again uh next week
thanks so much pop i'm looking forward
to it man hope everybody likes the
newsletter as well